ميدانيا شحنه من صواريخ كروت الروسيه من
طراز كاليبر لم تصل الى وجهتها بل باغتها
انفجار ضخم خلال عمليه النقل وتدمرت تماما
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ودون تبني الحادث
اعلنت ان الشحنه استهدفت اثناء نقلها عبر
سكك الحديديه في منطقه جنكوي شمال شبه
جزيره القرم التي تعد موطنا لاحد اهم
المطارات العسكريه الروسيه هناك وتلعب
دورا مهما كخطا ذات صواريخ كاليبر او ما
تعرف بواحده من اهم الاسلحه في القصف
البري للبحريه الروسيه دخلت في الخدمه عام
1994 تم تصميم نموذجين من هذا الصاروخ
الذي يحلق بسرعه تقل عن سرعه الصوت احدها
مضاد للسفن والاخر مضاد للغواصات مع
القدره طبعا على حمل رؤوس نوويه يبلغ طول
الصاروخ نحو سته امتار ومدى عمل هي يتراوح
2500 كيلو متر قادر على التحليق على
ارتفاعات منخفضه للغايه وقد يحمل متفجرات
تزن نحو 450 كيلوغراما تقريبا منظومه
الملاحه الفضائيه الناشطه التي تعتمدها
صواريخ كاليبر تساعدها على المناوره فتلك
الصواريخ لا تتحرك الى الهدف في خط مستقيم
كما نشاهد هنا كما يمكن اطلاقها من انابيب
عموديه مثبته ومثبته على سفن صغيره يصل
طولها الى 200 قدم مثل الطردات على عكس
توماهوك الامريكي الذي ينتمي لنفس العائله
من صواريخ كروز ويتطلب اطلاقه سفنا يبلغ
طولها 500 قدم على الاقل في وقت مشاهدينا
تفاخرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بان صواريخ
كاليبر لن تنفذ تشكك استونيا واوكرانيا
وغيرها من الدول في ذلك مرجحه النفاذ
الصواريخ الروسيه خلال اشهر تشكيك قد
يبرره اعلانا الرئيس الروسي قبل شهر
تقريبا العمل بشكل سريع على زياده انتاج
خط كامل من الاسلحه التقليديه
[موسيقى]